-Looking good, buddy.
Welcome back to the show.
Thanks for being here.
-Thanks for having me.
Before we get into the notes,
I've been on the show
six, maybe seven times.
And a little offended.
We haven't played a game yet,
and I was wondering why
I'm always talking
and not, like,
participating in the fun games.
-Because you
kind of are the fun game.
-Oh, I am the game.
-Yeah, we want to...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright.
-We want to play -- We're all
playing right now with you.
You are the game.
I would love to play.
I'll pitch you a game
next time you come --
-Yeah, let's do it.
My mother's like,
"You playing a game?"
I go, "No, I'm talking again."
[ Laughter ]
-You're, like,
a professional talker.
-Yeah, yeah. I am.
I like talking.
But for my mom,
if we could play a game...
-Without a doubt,
I will play a game.
Mom, if you're watching,
I will --
Please, I will do anything.
I will play a game.
I would love to.
I'd be honored.
-Well, thank you.
-I want to --
What is Thanksgiving like?
Can you walk me through
what it's like
at the Maniscalco house?
-Normally, it's at
my mother's --
my mother-in-law's house
in Florida.
This year, due to logistics,
at my father's house.
And --
-Wow. What's that like?
-Mussels and octopus.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No turkey, no yams.
-What?!
-It's braciole,
eggplant, pasta --
what the Pilgrims ate.
[ Laughter ]
-Speaking of your dad,
I congratulated you backstage,
but I really mean this.
I know you're shooting a movie
based on your dad's life.
And you're playing you.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wait -- wait -- wait for this.
Your dad is being played by
Robert De Niro.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now we can clap.
Buddy.
-Yeah, it's...
We shot this thing
in Alabama for two months.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And...
Alabama's here tonight.
And --
-No, they're actually just
a fan of "two months."
-Oh. Two months.
-They love two months.
They go, "Oh, yeah, we were
waiting to hear Jimmy say it."
-Wait. But --
-So, yeah, so --
-But do you freak out?
I mean, that's your hero, man.
-It's -- Yeah, here's a guy
I grew up watching --
"Casino."
I used to work at
the Four Seasons Hotel.
I've waited on Robert De Niro.
-Yeah, I actually have
a picture of you
working at the Four Seasons.
-Yeah, that's me.
The Four Seasons.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And how was -- how was
Robert De Niro when you met him?
How was he?
-You know, quiet,
and, you know, he just --
He was eating a lot of almonds.
We gave, like, free snacks.
And this guy was
wolfing down almonds
like they were
going out of style.
And, subsequently, now,
15 years later,
he's playing my father.
So, my father comes to
the set because De Niro
wanted some help on
how to do highlights.
My dad's a beautician,
and in the movie,
there's a salon scene.
-Yeah.
-So my dad's showing De Niro
how do to highlights.
And my dad comes up to me
after he's done.
He's like, "How much am
I getting paid here?"
I'm like, "Dad --"
-Are you kidding?
-No. He wants a salary.
-"Dad, you're hanging out with
Robert De Niro."
-No, he's like, "I'm losing
clients back home to do this.
At least $1,000 a day."
-Yeah. Exactly. Exactly.
Dad. Oh, my gosh. Geez.
That is unbelievable.
You're in the middle of your
Nobody Does This Tour.
-Yes.
-Congrats on that.
You're so funny, buddy.
I've said it before,
but I really mean it.
And you crush these --
You sell out arenas.
You sold you Madison Square
Garden December 28th.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're gonna be at the
Barclays Center December 29th.
-Yes.
-What is it like to go out to
all those people?
I mean...
-You know, it's different.
You know, I started in
the comedy clubs,
graduated to theaters.
I never thought
I'd be doing arenas.
So, my act is kind of
tailor-made for arenas.
I'm kind of physical,
a lot of facial expressions,
what have you.
And it's nice to go out there
to, you know, 20,000 people.
It's a different energy,
obviously, than a theater
or a comedy club.
I think the comedy club, though,
is the best place to perform.
It's 150 people,
you know, right on top of you.
-But I think you do
something that a lot of --
For those giant arenas,
you do --
You have these
tiny, little nuances.
You'll go -- You'll make like
an "eh" or s--
They hear you.
They're listening for that "eh,"
and you get a giant laugh.
-Yeah.
-If I was doing a big arena,
I would scream the whole time.
"Oh, my gosh!
My dad -- he goes --"
And everybody's just yelling.
"Calm it down, buddy."
-You got a different style of
comedy, which is fine.
[ Laughter ]
You know, high energy,
always happy, always smiling,
and I look like
I'm falling into a coma.
So that's why people are like,
"eh," and then they laugh.
-"Eh" is great.
-Yeah.
-I want to talk about your show,
because how did it come about?
It's on discovery+,
which I do love.
But it's called "Well Done."
-"Well Done."
Yeah, it's a cooking show.
-Yeah.
-And over the pandemic --
I got a passion for food --
I was cooking, like,
breakfast, lunch, and dinner.
I felt like I was running a
hotel over the pandemic.
-Yeah, of course.
-I was really doing
a lot of cooking.
I was like, "How do I marry the
culinary arts with comedy?"
So I came up with
a show called "Well Done."
It's 13 episodes
around things that
I'm really interested
in the culinary arts --
sushi, steak, dog food.
We did an episode on dog food.
Bartending.
And it's fun.
It's different than stand-up.
-Like, what is dog food?
Like, what do you mean?
You, like --
-You know, I don't have a dog,
and I used to make --
[ Laughter ]
Is that odd?
-Well, I think
it's just interesting --
You want to get
in the dog-food business?
-Well, I used to make fun of
people who used to go to
these "gourmet" dog-food places.
I'm like, "What are they doing?
It's a dog."
So, I went to investigate
what's going on at these places
and I learned that, actually,
it's better food for the dog.
It's like --
They serve chicken and beef,
like what we would eat,
but not seasoned.
-Yeah. That's --
-You interested in this?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I want to take a look at a clip.
Here's a peek at "Well Done..."
[ Laughter ]
"Well Done with
Sebastian Maniscalco."
Take a look at this.
-Is that a good amount?
-Yeah. Mm-hmm.
-And we put it
right in the middle?
-Yes.
-Three cucumbers
right behind the tuna.
And sprouts?
-Sprouts.
-Okay.
Now we're gonna roll, right?
-Yes.
-It's like you're very
particular about how it's done.
This is very similar to
stand-up comedy.
The joke needs to be told right.
The timing needs to be there.
-Yeah, let's see your work.
-My first roll
looked exactly like Saito's...
if it had been
run over by a minivan.
-That's exactly right.
Sebastian Maniscalco.
[ Cheers and applause ]
New episodes of "Well Done
with Sebastian Maniscalco"
premiere every Tuesday
on discovery+.
And check out his
Nobody Does This Tour.